こんにちははじめシャトーです当然なんですけどもコードドラゴンブラッドという
ゲーム皆さんご存知でしょうか
僕も見たときもアプリのランキング1位だったんではすげーと思ったんですけどそれ
から人気のゲームで今始め祭というキャンペーンが実施されております
あの肇社長のはじめ祭りじゃなくてドラゴンブラッドが始まるよって意味のはじめ祭り
ですねこのキャンペーンが4月の
26日もうすぐ終わっちゃうんでまだ間に合いますのでみなさんぜひ参加してみて
ください豪華ですこの両面
ということで今日も動画を撮っていきます生姜ドラゴンブラッドも名前の通りドラモン
が出てくるゲームなんですけども
所までそのドラを見てるだけですこちら
この子どこの子これをこの子
[音楽]
今でできた所なんかもめっちゃくちゃかっこよくないですか
そこで私は思ったんですよもしヒゲにあのドラゴンがいたら人はどうなってしまうけど
今日は実験していきたいとおもいます
だけでも実はですね特注で8通しても上にセッティングしてあります僕もちょっと
初めて滅菌としてますけど
さっそく見ていきましょう
tan
dee
[音楽]
me
これ見にこれも実は超えてるのいきますよ
オレはー
んえーすごいどちらが今回のドラマが待ってますやばいやば
えええええええ
いや僕なんかロケットここに作ったことあったんですけどそのレベルと違うぞ俺はもう
屋バー
海南から飼ってるわけじゃないですねこうやって上がってきたらもうこれですよ
履いてる人見ていきましょう頭これすごくないですか
もうドラゴンの頭でございますこのあううっ座れば天井の壁をぶち破りあるが感じ
akb 本当についててる数えてロス
すすめですねてってってってやばいやばいばいやもうこのさーちゃん問われてる感じで
まずれすごいと思うんですよね本当に
そしてことが翼ですねスーパーさの翼でしっかり
僕の家の天井にめり込んでおります
[音楽]
母
生えただけでいいからでしょうかこちら私の良いにドラグんめ来ました
これ誰がどうみたよこっからまで行けば上がってきてこうなってたらの絶対にドラゴン
が天皇物止めていきたいと思うわけですよ
そしてさらにドラゴンダメにご注目ください
期間ですいやいやモンコレ光ったらもうよ嫌よこれ
よくこんなことになったら俺んち本当にあの
業者の方本当にありがとうございますこんなんでがすごい怖いです
山井さん名筆管ですよこれも日本語でそうすると思っちゃっでます
と夕食早速挑んターゲット選んでいきましょー
烈子
なぜかやってい
あった
sai うわぁ
ああああああ
ro ああああ
passo a 何これくれる便が
うちにいつなドラゴンがいるドッキリでしたよこいつが深くなるか
カッコいいこれやばいでしょマック家っていう
一応俺これ語彙力
はいはいこれはー
ああああああ
ああああああああバーリこれ
以下
またやったねーこれ別に来るとドロン蛙とっていうでしたあーー
コア
惜しいいやーみんなリアクションがいいけど倒れるんですね
何か一つまた新たなことが分かりました家に入ってドラゴンが入ると人は倒れます
覚えてくださいではどんどん読んでいきましょう
[音楽]
さあを作ったらええええ
すごいなっても前はいはい f 5いうかすごいぞ
すごいとラッパ co
パワー風
すごい時をすごいけど一番すごいこれ
びっくりする人は死にもせん
大友達から
アーカイブ5位
はいはいはい
a
えっうわああああっはぁ
パス型と言いはドラゴンに大勢だものにかかるのか
いやば g-dragon 友達なんだねなんてかかったです
清は予約
ジャイえええっいましたよいう
はいはい
スレ car
[音楽]
はいどうでしたが迫力ハンパないですねいいでしょう
いいですねぜひ3つとん
持って帰ってください
いただきます本当ですねはい俺だけ三杯的で前にドッキリ仕掛けてなんですけども
めっちゃ頬カッターですドラゴン自体はこの空想の生き物なんでいないんですけど実際
に言うと今くらい強いんですよねやっぱドラゴンって
まあ中にはビビらなかったと思いましたけどまぁ結果は結構成功だったのかなって思い
ます
本当に出ているが細いドローンができて良かったです実験足がドッキリ大成功でござい
ますというわけで今回作ったこのドラゴンが登場するコードドラゴンぶらっとどういう
ゲームかといいますと
最近めっちゃ話題の ma も rpg のスマホゲームなんですけども
本当に操縦で何でも遊べるみたいでスポーツいう事前にキャラ作れてもキャラメイクが
めっちゃ
鈴湯でもう僕はず目社長に似せたキャラなんかを作ることができます常にキャラは4つ
の中から職業が選べるんですけども僕は攻撃魔法魔法で攻撃する執行さという職業で
ございますでもコードが労務ラット何が特徴だと言いますとあの僕は自体やってみて
グラフィックがめっちゃくちゃキレイなんですよ
ここにドラゴン取らせ
2頭身とかもめっちゃくちゃド派手でかっこよかったですさらにいろいろな乗り物に
乗って東京の夜景とかドライブして楽しむことができるですよめっちゃ綺麗じゃない
ですか
あとは特装的なのがカーレース
忍足ドラゴンに乗ったりバスケをしたり温泉に入ったりもできる
もういろんな方ができるのがコードドラゴンブラッドの特徴です
ただけで最初にも言ったんですけども今始め待ってるというキャンペーンを実施して
おります締め切りが26日なので明日までやっておりますまだの方は是非投稿してみて
ください
動画の概要欄にあるみんカラコードドラゴンブラッドあった
ロードして遊べますのでぜひ皆さんが遊んでみてください本当にグラフィックや
ヴァイスか皆さんこうドラゴンブラッドほんと中度が高いのでぜひ遊びくださいじゃあ
な